they say revenge is a dish best served
cold but in esports it's a dish best
served
well in a server everyone loves a
healthy vendetta whether it's a career
spanning blood feud or an org scorned
which is why we put together our list of
the absolute best examples but before we
get into that list don't forget to
subscribe to score esports that way
you'll never miss a video just like this
one and with that let's get into our top
10 revenge stories in esports
starting us off at number 10 is the time
damn one gaming exacted their revenge on
g2 esports at the 2020 league of legends
world championships g2 trying to hold on
to hope dan want gaming though set their
sights on the nexus down one gaming set
their sights on the final they look to
g2 they take their time with but they
sweep aside the lec and for the first
time in three years the lck will advance
to the world final all the way back in
2019 it looked as if dam 1 gaming were
poised to help south korea reclaim its
throne as league's most dominant region
but their cinderella story was cut short
in the quarterfinals by g2 it certainly
was a g2 series
and as they move in and as they close
the game they will knock don juan gaming
out of the tournament and g2 will move
on to the semi-finals for the msi
rematch versus skt the last of the lck
versus the last of the lec
downward gaming follow that up with an
incredible 2020 season that once again
saw them face off against g2 at worlds
this time in the semi-finals it was time
for dan juan to exact their revenge and
they weren't playing around
they look to g2 they take their time
with but they sweep beside the lec and
for the first time in three years the
lck will advance to the world final
after a commanding 3-1 series win dan
juan decided to add a little insult to
injury by mocking a previous g2
celebration they would then go on to win
worlds making this revenge story that
much sweeter shanghai and darmward
gaming are your season 2020 world
champion
coming in at number nine spot is the
iconic revenge match between taquito and
daigo at 2020's topanga championship
taquito is one of the most dominant
street fighter 5 players out there and
daigo has been handing out ass whoopings
longer than some pros have been alive
[Applause]
after years of anticipation the two
finally got to face off in a first
attempt series which is seen by the
community as the ultimate test of might
it was a great series but aikido would
end up losing 10 to 5.
the loss crushed to kedo but two years
later dekido would get his second
opportunity to face daigo in another
long series
[Music]
and with the whole world watching he was
able to get his revenge and defeat the
one player he had always looked up to
taking the number eight spot on our list
are the shanghai dragons and their
revenge against the entire overwatch
league yeah you heard that one right the
tragic tale of the shanghai dragons is
one as old as time in the overwatch
league's inaugural season they were a
team that on paper looked pretty solid
that is until they lost every single
game ending the season with an
unimaginable 0 and 40 record welcome
back everyone to the desk here for the
post game as the san francisco shock
will win 4-0 and that means that the
shanghai dragons are oh and 40 in the
season simply put they were a joke
amongst the community but over the
off-season they made some much needed
changes to both their roster and front
office then after two losses they
finally got their first win and well the
people went [ __ ] nuts
but it does not matter ladies and
gentlemen history has been made the
shanghai dragons and the 43rd
[Applause]
but that wasn't their revenge story not
even close their revenge truly came in
2021 when the shanghai dragons became
the most dominant team in the overwatch
league concluding one of esports
greatest rags to riches stories
pop and they're so close a minute 15
left in the atlanta reign have nothing
left to work with the dragons teachers
that if we want to climb high we must do
it against the wind the shanghai dragons
i got 20 21 overwatch league champions
the seventh spot on our list goes to
canadian and his revenge against all his
haters canadian isn't just known in the
r6 community as a two-time invitational
winner he's also one of the greatest
[ __ ] talkers that the esport has to
offer
why am i so much
better than you but for a long time he
was also known as one of the biggest
chokers of all time back at the season 9
pro league finals canadian and his eg
squad wrong match and championship point
but we all know what happened next
down on white stairs waiting for the
vault on in is canadian will he be able
to secure the kill he sees the tracers
go oh no scyther will win the fight
he'll inch his way on up geo's going to
be next in line but this could be a
tough shot and empire could wrestle away
the round there's geo just waiting he
doesn't pull the trigger he sees it he
pops up oh no geo you gotta hit your
shots young will be the last one left he
was so important for faze he turns his
back he's got the pistol but shepard
will deny the comeback from eg on that
round and nbk will watch as geo goes for
the plant the sound q will give damn the
information oh he takes one down
empire will rise as you crown a new
champion here in milan after that loss
canadian and the rest of eg were
considered to be certified chokers but
when canadian left to join space station
gaming the fiery veteran found himself
leading a dominant team that secured a
spot in the 2026 invitational finals
against nip with some incredible
leadership from canadian ssg were able
to beat the brazilians and the veteran
siege player managed to reverse the
narrative and exact his revenge against
those who doubted him that's it he'll
head in towards archives and get caught
the hammer heads into orbit but it's
home once again is north america
space station gaming are your world
champions
[Applause]
everyone can relate to a relationship
gone sour which is why the sixth place
on our list goes to crim6 and the
revenge he exacted against his former
team krimzy was an integral part of
cementing the optic dynasty but in 2019
he was dropped and claimed he was being
forced out what's worse is that his
former teammate started talking trash
about him uh
arrogant cocky
just
literally
teenagers that are old men like
just flamboyant is that a good word yeah
well i have a perfect word yeah this
started the crims revenge tour he would
join the dallas empire and quickly made
them one of the best teams in the league
along the way he was able to get his
first taste of revenge when he threw his
former teammates i think it may be over
i think that maybe all she wrote for the
chicago huntsman here is the dallas
empire they have absolutely stormed
their way through the first two maps and
there was great signs of life here for
chicago in the dom but at the end of the
day it was a few key moments a few
magical plays there on the flags from
dallas and they've only gone and done it
29 and 17 for shotsy in the end and it's
a swift 3-0 but it doesn't stop there
things got even more heated when formal
and crim got into it on twitter this
sets up the perfect grudge match when
the major 4 came around the first
tournament back on lan optic were
expected to steamroll empire but krimsix
would ultimately get his revenge you
only need 10 more seconds and it's on
skump and dash to the two stellar
hardpoint players all weekend long for
them but to dallas in their early lead
the break at the second hill are they
able to hold on they are dallas they
deal with the comeback they win the
first match optic with the position and
the trade they're just doing everything
they can to try and stop the clock if
your empire they've got to go and
they've got to go now
elio get in not for long he will drop in
optic will close out the round
just a couple seconds needed an empire
take both hard points they take the
series later on crimson empire would get
knocked out of the major five but he
took the high road and buried the
hatchet with his former teammate
cracking the top five on our list is
alexi b and the revenge he got against
his former org ends but this is the
first time lexie b has played his old
team in quite a long stretch of time
since he left them he'll be smiling your
ear to to take the win against them
there's so many layers in this one as
well because sunny was the guy replacing
him he was being brought into this
lineup because they wanted to be the
best team in the world they wanted to
add more firepower in towards the end's
lineup in 2019 ants and their newly
adjusted roster would go on an
incredible miracle run at the katowice
major with igl alexi b calling the shots
ent would stun the world and make it to
their first ever major finals and
although they would go on to lose the
squad looked great and cultivated a
devoted fan base but just a few months
after the major alexie b was benched and
replaced the move baffled most and the
decision quickly backfired on ants as
their results started to dwindle alexi b
signed with og's first ever csgo roster
and would get his shot at revenge
against his former org in a highly
anticipated grudge match and he's on the
case nine seconds left nearly a
one-on-one with the nade going far he
knows the second player was on top of
the site three hp manchu's gonna walk
out and go down but a jump up alexi b
not only did og two owe them but alexi b
got the final kill on the one who
replaced him now we know that ice.bet
2020 might not have been the most
prestigious tournament but the 2-0
victory was felt by the community alexie
b was back and to this day things
haven't been so easy for ends
the fgc has no shortage of great
rivalries and even better revenge
stories which is why the fourth place on
our list goes to tweet's quest for
vengeance against mk leo the story
starts at evo 2019 when tweek and mk leo
would face off in the grand finals tweek
would get the first two games on leo but
a costly mistake in game four would deny
the clutch victory and reset the match
this could go either way
oh he reads him but he does not pull the
trigger on that board and now this could
take him out
oh
tweak
so close to clutching it out but unable
to find it right there and you saw he
had that read on that role from there
things only got worse for tweak as leo
would go on to win evo itself he missed
it he grabbed the ledge and with that fk
leo defeats tweet to be your 2019 evo
champion what followed was one of the
worst losing streaks in smash history as
tweek wouldn't win a single game against
leo in five different sets over four
different tournaments but in 2021 tweets
look finally changed at smash summit 3.
very
[ __ ] close
that's it
would finally get his revenge and defeat
leo in both winners and then again in
the grand final to take the tournament
and exact his revenge
coming in third place is a revenge story
like no other it's cure by and the time
he bested astralis ladies and gentlemen
may i present to you
your champions
of dreamhack master stockholm 2018
make some noise
astralis is one of if not the greatest
lineup to ever touch cs go which makes
the story of kirby even more bizarre you
see after astralis first major win all
the way back in 2017 kierbaugh made a
decision that would shock the entire
csgo community he left astralis yes
kierby left the team that he had just
won a major with to join a small danish
team named north yeah we would just
have appreciated a conversation about it
because
also still at the moment we really don't
know why he left
so yeah it's a bit sad but um i hope
that he does well and when i see him at
events we say hi and i still feel like
we can get a good relationship out of it
but
it's just yeah it's just sad to feel
betrayed in some way for years care
kirby would get memed on by the
community for leaving a team that went
on to become a cs go dynasty that is
until dreamhack masters stockholm 2018.
australis were practically at their peak
and everyone assumed that they would win
the tournament but kierby's north team
was on fire they beat everyone in their
group including astralis then went on to
smash navi and mouse sports before
meeting astralis again in the finals as
good as north looked there was no way
they could beat astralis again right
[Applause]
after all the hate kirby finally got the
revenge he was looking for
the runner-up spot on our list goes to
league of legends most iconic rivalry sk
telecom vs samsung galaxy the skt
dynasty is over
back in 2016 ssg were inches away from
pulling off a miracle run at worlds
simply put ssg dominated their group and
smashed everyone in their way to make it
to the world's finals against faker and
the rest of sk telecom after losing the
first few games samsung galaxy almost
pulled off the reverse sweep to win but
their dreams were crushed by the game's
most feared dynasty duke who flashes
forward chomps down to kill crowd sk
telecom i've got two make that three
kills sk telecom have overcome every
challenge ssg didn't look nearly as
strong the following year they already
lost to skt in the summer finals and
just barely made it to worlds through
the gauntlet despite all that they
managed to have another successful run
at the 2017 league of legends world
championship making it back to the
finals and this time they took care of
business
they've pot baker they've got the cc the
mid laner is down the unkillable demon
king has done just that the sjc dynasty
is over fans got the rematch they wanted
and ssg got their revenge in the form of
an incredible sweep beating skt 3-0
the number one spot on our list goes to
esports most epic revenge story of
course we're talking about dota 2's fly
and no tail the story goes like this
once upon a time fly and no tail were
best buds who competed at dota 2's
highest level together they made some
great memories and even won some
tournaments along the way but
unfortunately they couldn't win the most
important dota 2 tournament of the year
the international after years of coming
up short on dota's biggest stage flying
left the team that he founded alongside
his best friend and joined the
star-studded evil geniuses roster in the
hopes of finally winning the
international we spent eight years
together and now it's over
that was how that happened
no tail was left feeling heartbroken and
betrayed but he didn't give up and at
ti-8 with the power of hard work and
friendship no tail was able to get his
revenge against fly when they met in the
upper bracket and they're coming in
gerax as well
he's got a rapier but it's almost
certainly they're going back
looking to close things up they're on to
the agent they're beating it down at a
pace and he can't compare
oh gee
win the series
it was very gratifying
revenge and anger
it's
not the healthiest emotions
[Music]
the rest is back-to-back ti winning
history
[Applause]
wow revenge doesn't get any sweeter than
that well that was our list guys what
did you think of that were there any
stories out there that should have made
it onto the list let us know also let us
know what you want to see next on the
channel thanks for watching and as
always i'll see you all in the next one
life this isn't a [ __ ] game as simple
as that
you said say it to my face right now
all right all right
all right all right all right i'm sorry
i'm getting it
and that's it and that's it
he is popping off right now there's
gonna come a point when you forget about
what happened and you're going to want
to come back at me
and you're going to want to wash the
taste of my dick out of your mouth